economía/empresas 24 me acompaña en el
estudio àngel hablando con daniela
bienvenida ya hay reacciones al acuerdo
entre eeuu y alemania sobre el gasoducto
nor swe 2 hola raúl pues los gobiernos
de estos dos países como ya lo habíamos
anunciado dijeron que llegaron a un
acuerdo que cesa a su larga disputa
sobre la construcción del gasoducto que
conecta directamente a rusia con
alemania ya reaccionaron oponentes al
proyecto como por ejemplo ucrania y
polonia países de tránsito de muchos
gasoductos
frente al avance de las obras del
gasoducto eeuu aceptó lo evidente no
podrá impedir la construcción del nord
stream 2 entre rusia y alemania-
washington abandonó las sanciones
impuestas a las empresas participantes
en 2019 y llegó a un acuerdo con berlín
adsense johnson
es poco probable que las sanciones
impidan que se materializa el gasoducto
sin
taiwán diesel menestra esta
administración ha juzgado que es
contrario a nuestros intereses
perjudicar la relación bilateral de
aliados que tenemos con alemania
sin embargo la casa blanca persiste en
sus críticas al gasoducto basadas en que
rusia pueda utilizar la dependencia
energética de europa como un arma de
influencia
de hecho el gas ruso ya representa un 40
por ciento del consumido en europa el
north stream 2 desarrollado al 98% debe
conectar directamente rusia y alemania-
los estadounidenses temen que rusia deje
de usar el gasoducto que pasa por
ucrania y que reporta 7000 millones de
euros anuales aquí
para atenuar el poder ruso el acuerdo
con berlín estipula la posible
aplicación de sanciones a moscú pero
kiev de la mano de polonia critica el
acuerdo entre eeuu y alemania un tema
que según el ejecutivo de ucrania estará
en la agenda de la cita entre joe biden
y su homólogo ucraniano wladimir
selenski en washington el 30 de agosto
danielle banco central europeo deseo
mantener los estímulos a la economía
hubo una reunión del consejo de gobierno
de la cosa decidió mantener las tasas de
interés en cero por ciento esto para
estimular el consumo esta es la tasa a
la que les presta a los bancos lo que ve
el banco central europeo es que hay
optimismo pero la variante delta va a
obstaculizar sobre todo la recuperación
del turismo y la hostelería escuchamos
la recuperación de la economía de la
zona euro va por buen camino cada vez
más personas se vacunan las
restricciones de cierre se han suavizado
en la mayoría de los países de la región
pero la pandemia sigue proyectando
sombras especialmente dado que la
variante delta constituye una fuente
creciente de incertidumbre sofán sanchis
y congresista de eeuu se evalúan el
acuerdo comercial con méxico y canadá
así es de raúl la secretaria de economía
de méxico tatiana clouthier se encontró
en washington con la representante
comercial de ese país es catherine type
para evaluar cómo va el acuerdo
comercial entre estos dos países más
canadá que entró en vigencia hace más de
un año sin embargo senadores y
congresistas de ese país enviaron una
carta al presidente joe biden para
denunciar la política energética
proteccionista de andrés manuel lópez
obrador así la llaman por limitar el
acceso a los mercados de las compañías
estadounidenses en su famosa y muy
polémica reforma eléctrica situación de
méxico es excepcional es inmejorable
para la inversión algunos que
protestan pero es una minoría
no es significativo daniela indicadores
o street acumuló el jueves tres jornadas
consecutivas al alza raúl en una semana
repleta de resultados empresariales y a
la espera también de los resultados de
las empresas tecnológicas que se van a
publicar la próxima semana y en
latinoamérica también tenemos que hubo
resultados dispares aunque sin grandes
variaciones en medio de la cautela de la
cautela que hay por las dudas sobre la
recuperación económica tras la pandemia
del cob y de 19 y para finalizar le
pregunto qué nos trae hoy como cifra el
día 419.000 raúl a esta cifra volvieron
a subir las peticiones de subsidio por
desempleo en eeuu
este es un mayor nivel en dos meses
después de que pues por varias semanas
estuviera en mínimos desde el inicio de
la pandemia recordemos que esas
peticiones tuvieron un pico de 6,8
millones en marzo del año pasado cuando
estábamos en pleno pico de la pandemia y
antes eran de 200 mil al mes así que ya
nos estamos
y como siempre gracias a ustedes también
gracias continúen con nosotros